does University turn people into idiots
is Berkeley California full of hippies
and men who smell like their own urine I
don't know about you but I just had to
find out for myself I'd recently been
reading arguing with idiots by Glenn
Beck and I realized that I'd heard most
of the idiot arguments before in college
see college is a haven for liberals so
much so that simply saying the name UC
Berkeley immediately incites a mental
image dude my professor totally opened
my eyes I'm like totally enlightened now
brah and with the stats showing just how
left leaving the halls of higher
learning really are how could you come
out any other way I mean is it any
surprise that an establishment which
relies on a constant stream of federal
funding would be incentivized to promote
liberal or socialist ideology well you
say socialists like it's a bad thing see
that's the problem is that we made
socialism a dirty word in America brah
but how much are people really learning
at these expensive universities I mean
UC Berkeley students are attending the
number-one-ranked public university in
the country so do they know more than
the average bear okay what they can't
all be gems they can't all be gems this
is steven crowder at the university of
california at berkeley and we want to
see what one of the nation's top schools
is teaching their kids about America so
will we find any idiots here we'll let
you know I've got my Berkeley garb and
my Berkeley beard or what I can grow I
think we're good to go do I look like
Kurt Cobain Jared No who is your
favorite United States president and why
my favorite United States president
[Music]
how many questions are there by the way
I guess that's kind of a question answer
but I'll say Abraham Abraham I'm gonna
go ahead and say Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
Abe Lincoln was easily the most popular
naming the party of the old dude with
the beard and hat a little more daunting
and to what party today really
I'll say yeah I'm not sure um back then
I believe he was a Republican but that
was nominally a Republican
well she's basically right it was a
subjective question so we decided to ask
a more straightforward one what do you
think caused the Great Depression
oh that's an interesting what caused the
Great Depression Wow
the Great Depression
the first one I don't know I guess like
the stock market crashed
[Music]
yep Black Friday it was a black day so
nobody answered correctly with the
Federal Reserve but we thought we'd let
them take a stab as to how it was fixed
[Music]
you know they go offer to fix it geez
you can't even give these folks the
right answer you know fairness that
stuff happened a long time ago let's try
something a little more current some
people think that the assault weapons
ban act is a good thing because it bans
machine guns here in the streets what do
you think I don't like machine guns
really against machine guns yeah yeah I
mean in terms of how well it works like
I'm sure there's like Russian mafia and
some Chinese triads or something has
machine guns but whatever like in terms
of people having machine guns yeah the
Second Amendment was written in a very
different time socially it was a time
when people lived mostly rural lives it
was also a time after a huge rebellion
against unjust government and so people
were actually unjust what do you mean by
that I mean at the time I use quotation
marks because obviously it's up to
interpretation but I say yeah there was
there's some pressures put on American
people that maybe were unjustified but I
also think that those revolutionary
people in American history were maybe
blowing those issues up a little more
it's looking more and more like
university is not only incapable of
protecting you from idiocy but it may
actually encourage it but how could you
expect them to know anything when
students oftentimes have an attitude
like this
[Music]
[Applause]
cried because facts and statistics
that's not why you go to college you go
for things like keggers a revisionist
history she makes it sound like
Americans started slavery by capturing
folks as opposed to a large portion of
them being sold from African slave
traders themselves but I'm sure she can
answer to that but isn't that your job
so you have to understand that in
universities the demonization of the
United States is practically part of the
curriculum it just so happens that in
Berkeley they start even younger than
most now how does one become such an
idiot well here in Berkeley the
indoctrination starts young as you can
see we're right outside of a famous
mural in front of a private grade school
[Music]
17,000 years so your son can write that
capitalism will fail and the problem is
little guy that if you don't have enough
capital you won't be able to buy your
weed it's exasperating I know well how
about the student organizations they've
got to be a better example of the
upstanding student body right we're
trying to help organize right now
there's a lot stuff about the bailouts
so he would support like budget cuts
sorry bailout yeah you know I'm like I'm
a big chick over a fan okay people are
try and say Oh Jay killed all these
people's like yeah but you understood
the historical context why did he kill
you know thousands people wasn't for no
reason it's not like you just did it
Cuba now despite what we see on TV it's
a lot better off for it so nothing but
nets
so like but nothing else but Nazism what
about DDT
things with a net is if you're outside
of your bed for these six hours a day
that you're not sleeping you're screwed
thank you yes it is
he did he's a war criminal
just in case there were any doubt as to
whether liberals would politicize the
death of Ted Kennedy
all right woody what are you doing for a
Ted Kennedy
you know it was those tragic what
happened - same thing with Mary Jo
Kopechne Jeannot Jeannot Mary Jo
Kopechne is supporting this
ya know I just want to sign this in
memory of Ted you know for Mary Jo
Kopechne you supporting this I I don't
know I know I think she is though
[Music]
it's looking more and more like
University is not only incapable of
protecting you from idiocy but it may
actually encourage it but amidst all of
this there was one fine example one
glimmer of hope who is your favorite
present and wide
finally a couple of smart Dame's
Benjamin Franklin yes America Benjamin
Franklin was our finest president the
one with the book
was awesome it's totally awesome
[Music]